not done going through hell yet
when the packs started to flee the city
monroy rounded up every last one of them
that stayed behind
that were loyal and trusting and threw
them into these
labor camps but i know of the packs they
could not have survived long in there
it was almond roy when he understood the
packs were turning into ferals he sent
out an order to murder them all before
they could transform
all of them all but enough to run his
camp
so
foreign
it's a diary from nikolai galliadkin
from roy's general
seems he was overcome with remorse at
the end for what he had been a part of
he didn't retreat to the caravan he
decided to walk away from it all
right into an anomaly good
monroy returned to the city to find it
under siege
they battled for days a complete
bloodbath
and then another storm hit monroy's
people were decimated
that's when they spotted the flores in
orbit and called for help
they started broadcasting the signal but
it couldn't get through
help never came and roy ordered a
retreat to their ship
and locked it down
so
all this time all we've been through
the battlefields the jungles the alien
ruins
the desert all we've lost i can't
believe we're finally here
the goddamn signal i heard the day we
landed and still
none of it makes any sense
oh i think i'm starting to put it all
together the way the packs controlled
the anomaly with their obelisks
they are what kept the planet's energy
in check
they were the balance but when monroy
stopped the packs from using the
obelisks out of pure
fear of what he couldn't understand the
anomaly spread like
wildfire across the planet the storm
surging out of control
mutating everything all this time
thinking we were going to reach a place
beyond the anomaly only to find the
place it all
started where monroy started
but roy
my father told me about the hordes
thousands climbing over each other
trying to reach the floor as
it launched they're the ones who got
left behind
and half of them probably slaughtered
the rest for a last seat on the caraval
tanner and jakob we all should have been
down there with the rest
hopeless drowning in chaos nothing but
dictators and mad men set loose
if the caravan hadn't exploded and
killed most of the outriders
we would have been the ones left on
earth two more soldiers in monroe's damn
army
fighting for any way off the earth
coming here to slaughter the packs
and screwing up the whole damn planet
before you all ever set foot on it
i'm inside the ship still operational
let's finish this the end of the road
one way or another despite everything
we've brought the uplink all this way
i wish jane could see us
whatever's playing the signal it's in
here
let's finish
37.5673 degrees north
22.80116 degrees
look it's exactly as i saw it
it is we saw it janna
that's not real that's this planet all
right but
it's long gone no
no get the [ __ ] off
gotta go away i'm in the mood for this
today
you okay
i imagine this so many times
never you who are you
who am i
[Laughter]
roy how how did you how did this ship
get here before us
how do you think
you people left us to die as the earth
crumbled
but i don't die so easy do i now we
built a new engine
an engine that chained all others before
so while you were still crawling through
deep space we were already here
oh you should have seen it the primitive
civilization
the natives they treated us like god
yeah
i've seen what you did to the natives
i see now this isn't a rescue
why didn't you come when we said has a
distress call
30 years since the flores arrived in our
skies
30 years surviving in this hell this
hell
was because of you my entire
life trapped in that valley slaughtering
each other for nothing
you robbed our people of hope before we
even got here
don't flatter yourselves you were as
capable of every wickedness
the plaques weren't as docile as they
looked they had powers
so much power things i
had to understand so you just rounded
them up
you tortured them you son of a [ __ ]
are you ready to rave
how long before those creatures tired of
us
before they turned against us they would
have had us on our bloody knees
all that i wanted was their powers for
us
for all of us so that we could survive
so we could be strong
don't you see we lost the earth
because we were meant for something more
there but for the grace of i go you
my child
do you think that you would be standing
there the powers of a god if it hadn't
been for me
all that i've done for humanity
i saved us you cursed us
but i won
it's done [ __ ] him
no more wasting time i have to tap the
uplink into the caravan's power so we
can reach the floor is before we
[ __ ] we found us we gotta go no
no leave me i have to do this
do what you got to do doc that door
won't hold long
outrider if that beast cracks this
ship's hull we lose electronics we lose
the pods we lose everything
i'll take care of it you just get those
pods down
foreign
me
um
okay
so
so
wow
tahiti what's happening in there
it's working i've contacted the flores
transmitting the first launch codes now
[Music]
almost there almost there
i have to transmit the code
[Music]
the pods are more important than me
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
tiago get in i'm
not losing any more friends
oh [ __ ] i guess it's over
the signal the uplink
it was all for nothing
wait guys look over there
the parts it works
you did it my god
i guess some of the commands went
through after all
wow like i always say
it ain't over till it's over
what the hell when roy's people
no i don't think so
who are you we're from the war zone
are you the outriders we heard tales
about an altered outriders
opening the frontier finding a cure in
the forest
we've been following your trail
since the war zone
so what now we keep moving
uh
[Music]
so
ah
[Music]
the buds
they did it the [ __ ] did it
you